you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines for us this evening
we'll be joined by jake wallace simons
and susie boniface there they are ready
and raring to go there will be with us
until midnight so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
the telegraph leads with professor chris
whittie's comments that the delta
variant is of greater concern to the uk
than the new omicron variant
following that same story the mail says
that health chiefs have called for calm
heads and say there is no threat to
christmas
but the express says that the only quran
variant could impact the festive season
the financial times writes about stocks
and all prices sliding in response to
the new variant
the mirror says that scientists worry
that the new omicron variant might be in
the uk
the guardian writes about a covid
omicron variant case being detected in
belgium
the times leads with a story on the
diplomatic situation between the uk and
france their headline migration snub
will cost lives french told
the son writes that an intruder came
onto the i'm a celebrity set and was
within yards of the show's stars
and the daily star have a story on the
fire brigade being called after chef
jamie oliver burnt his toast we also
include an exclusive guide to making
toast
never got the recipe for that uh we're
joined tonight by the deputy editor of
the jewish chronicle jake wallace simons
and daley mirror economist susie
boniface welcome to you both thanks very
much for
joining us this evening um let's have a
look at the um telegraph um
first of all and they're leading with
professor chris whittie's comments that
the delta variant
is a greater concern in the uk than the
new omicron variant um slightly
different um stories depending on on the
papers as to how uh devastating this new
variant might be susie
yeah if you um
where an alien has come down from mars
you'd think there were 57 different
versions of of a being called chris
whittie who'd been speaking to different
journalists all day and then they'd all
said something different
um whereas if you actually sort of go
through something what he actually said
was that he gave a fairly wide ranging
uh discussion in which he said look you
know immediately
delta is our biggest concern this winter
but omicron is now a thing uh we need
we're still a bit unaware of what it may
do in terms of our vaccines or the
ability to reinfect us and we need to be
careful and it's something we may need
to think about perhaps slowing down the
spread of omicron because that produces
huge benefits in the long run it's going
to come in eventually but if you can
slow it down perhaps with border
controls
and things like face masks then it can
you know make it a bit easier to deal
with that's that's actually what he said
but what you've got here is a is a
fairly even
right left split from someone saying
from papers that are saying
uh
covert is fine don't worry about this
christmas is on and on the other side of
the argument some of the more left-wing
papers going whoa panic it's all going
to go horribly wrong uh turkey's off
the only answer to it i suppose is to
read all the newspapers which i i don't
think i'd wish for anybody
jake what what sort of message do you
think is being uh
put out this this evening or will be put
out to in tomorrow's newspapers
well i mean i think i have
two main takeaways from looking at the
papers uh this evening i mean the first
is that we really don't know very much
about this new variant or about how
transmissible it is or how deadly it
might be how vaccine resistant it might
be
there are early signs but it's it's
different from the others that the shape
of the virus cells uh is different
um and it does seem to be more
transmissible but we don't really know
more than that you know people haven't
died of it yet as far as we know
um and the infections that the symptoms
have so far seem to be quite mild but it
is spreading slowly now but but as we
all know uh it doesn't stay slow for
very long so people don't know very much
and we can see chris whitley and others
responding quite tentatively saying you
know it could be
a danger it could not be let's wait and
see let's take reasonable precautions um
so my first observation is it read that
we just don't know and that's a very
uncomfortable place for the media and
for the rest of us um to be in because
we want to know because of the fast past
couple of years
and my second observation really is that
it seems that as susie mentioned that
there is an even right left split on
this with the right wing papers saying
um let's all keep our heads and and be
careful not to overreact um you know
nobody wants another lockdown let's just
wait and see uh whereas the left-wing
papers seem to be far more um willing to
be quickly alarmed uh over this new
variant um and it seems it's a
fascinating thing now that covet has
become such a political matter such a
almost a political football used by the
the right to sort of you know bolster uh
their attitude towards freedom and the
left towards bearing towards perhaps
authoritarianism and it just seems a bit
sad that that's how things being treated
these days and susie it's very uh
difficult not to be alarmed we have the
the health secretary telling the commons
that the new variant may pose a
substantial risk to public health and
that early indications show this variant
may be more transmissible than the delta
variant and current vaccines may be less
effective against it that's direct quote
yeah um what we do know i mean jake's
right is there's a lot of sort of
uncertainty about it what we do know is
that where it has
been spreading in southern africa it's
it's increase in the population has been
exponential which isn't straight up by
that
in terms of the arc but uh what we also
know is some rather fantastic stuff
which if you consider where we were with
previous variants we certainly weren't
in the same place so early on so this is
very recently been discovered through
genetic sequencing we already know that
there are 30 particular mutations on the
spike protein we know what those
mutations would do what they should
make a difference to in the way the
virus works
and we know that 10 of them are in a
position on the spike protein which
causes us a fair bit of concern because
it may have an impact on vaccines and
infectiousness and so on added to which
we know tonight that modena is one of
the pharmaceutical companies which is
already working on a vaccine dealing
with exactly this genetic sequence so
what's happened is we've managed to
spread genetic sequencing around the
world we are sharing amongst our
scientists worldwide what those genetic
codes are and they are all piling in
with their um knowledge and expertise
from various academic institutions in
order to try to make the best possible
vaccine and give people the best advice
and work out what these changes on the
spike protein are going to mean for us
that puts us in the best position of any
humans who've ever had to have deal with
a plague in any time in history so we
are very very very fortunate
um
but the problem is that of course it
does tend to to move across borders it
does come in uh and
if you don't have some restrictions and
some controls which isn't necessarily
authoritarianism it can also be because
you wish to care for other people
then you you're not going to slow down
the progress of this new variant enough
to let science have their big strong run
up at it and get it get it fixed so
we're going to be looking in the next
few weeks maybe people starting to talk
about plan b and mask wearing again yes
but possibly we were looking there at
the end the guardian and their their
headline pointing to the fact that
domicrom has spread
to europe and in the the body of the
piece and suggesting that some
scientists are warning that it will
inevitably uh reach britain
jake
yes i mean you know susie's absolutely
right you know we are uh you know unique
in human history to have such advanced
scientific powers to counter pandemics
like this uh but i'll also add that that
we're in a particularly good place at
the moment in britain you know we had
our real uh bad time with kovid um a few
months back um in the you know first
wave the second wave where our death
rate and our infection rate was way way
ahead of europe but since then we've got
really ahead with the vaccines and our
natural immunity as a result of being
hit so hard before uh is more widespread
than europe and so they're having a
harder time than us but at the moment
really in this snapshot of time uh in
britain we are very well placed to deal
with this vaccine and of course or sorry
would deal with this uh with this uh
virus and of course in terms of the
vaccines um we have got there has been
the uh the invention of the mrna
type of vaccine which is the pfizer and
moderna
type of vaccine and the beauty of that
is that you can sort of insert into the
code a different type of virus that
you're going to be targeting and use the
same sort of bubble structure of the
of the vaccine to contain it and roll it
out to target a new variant and that's a
huge scientific development which has
been
an amazing benefit and the the the scope
for for the future uh benefits that will
give mankind is huge and so we are as
soon as it says you know in a lucky
position in britain and in this this day
and age and uh i find myself um you know
having managed to put a positive spin on
this rather alarming story well done
well done uh well we know that markets
can be spooked at the best of times and
they've certainly been spooked uh by
this with uh billions being uh wiped off
at share prices um susie this is the ft
that we're looking at now
yeah so um the markets have responded uh
to the wa show's announcement and it's
really interesting even if you're not
particularly economically minded to have
a look at what the markets are doing
because these are basically professional
gamblers and they're gambling with huge
amounts of money and they're using huge
amounts of data to try and uh guess
where the market is going next and so if
they're putting all their eggs in one
particular basket or taking them out of
one particular basket it's worth
noticing because you know it's it's like
the really good gamble in your betting
shop who suddenly puts a fiver on a nag
you won't you won't expect them to put a
fiver on that may be where you want to
put your money to and what they've done
is they've taken money out of the kind
of firms which are going to be exposing
pandemics and lockdowns and travel
restrictions so airline companies
holiday companies things like that and
the money is going into
businesses which do better out of the
pandemics so home deliveries uh online
only businesses that sort of thing so it
does seem that the markets are
particularly um cautious about this and
perhaps more cautious than some of the
wing papers and commentators might be
but i'd also like to say very quickly if
i can um that this is what happens when
you don't vaccinate the whole world you
get a variant that comes up from a part
of the world where the vaccinations are
really low well we'll see we're
um we start with this this gruesome
story come back with this gruesome story
in the mirror uh and this is the killing
of 12 year old ava smith headline there
killed on night out with pals
jake
i mean what can you what can you say
this this really is one of the most
disturbing
uh stories around uh at the moment uh in
the papers and there are many disturbing
stories um i mean the mirror have done a
fantastic job in uh devoting a spread to
this story pointing out that we've had
40 deaths of young people stabbing so
far this year which which is the worst
since 2008
and looks like you know given that the
year hasn't ended yet it looks like it
might even be
worse than that
and you know there are various different
uh reasons for it perhaps
um you know policing
has been in decline boris came to power
promising i think it was 40 000 more
police officers i'm not sure how he's
getting on with recruiting those but
certainly uh there does seem to be a
lack of police officers in urban areas
and deprived areas um that's that's the
first concern
labour used to have a scheme called
safer schools uh by which policemen were
attached to uh to schools um in
troubling uh that have a troubling
history or problem with with uh with
violence
that was disbanded in 2010 perhaps
returning that could help there's been
cuts in funding to urban areas the
mirror argues and that could be a reason
for it and of course the
impact of the pandemic again everything
seems to come back to the pandemic you
know lots of youth groups and various
other support networks were closed down
during the pandemic and some of them are
struggling to reopen again and so this
really is a tale i think of um of
deprivation hitting uh you know the the
britain's poorest and the forgotten
casualties of that are these young
people who are being knifed in the
street with alarming frequency and this
is something that really deserves the
attention that the mirror is giving it
jake thanks very much for that we are
running out of time but susie i wonder
if you can quickly take us into this
story in the daily telegraph which is
about um commonwealth countries being
seduced by china
yeah um so there's there's sort of
basically been a warning that uh beijing
is using hundreds of billions of pounds
about 700 billion to kind of seed
influence across the commonwealth so
these countries that used to be part of
the british empire and had sort of a
historic connection language connections
cultural connections to the uk um are
kind of are starting to move away
starting to have a business and cultural
links with china rather than with us uh
and the the impact that we'll have uh
barbados next week is going to be
declaring independence and losing the
queen as the head of state there's
feelings that jamaica might be next and
then therefore perhaps we're looking at
dismantling as a commonwealth and
perhaps china building it's only a
empire susie and jake thank you very
much